I'm a twin.
I had a brother, his name was Pietro. He was killed by Ultron. What did you say?
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my Wandavision episode 3 video there were
so many marvel easter eggs and references we'll
break it all down if you're new to the channel
i'm doing videos for all the Wandavision episodes
be sure to subscribe to get everything we're doing
a disney plus giveaway for memberships too all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
post your favorite wtf moment from the episode on
the video thankfully they are actually starting to
move the plot forward we're actually starting
to see more outside of this normal alternate
reality so careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet i'll just keep numbering
the easter eggs as we go along through the
episode there's way more than 10 easter eggs
even though i normally do top 10 wtf videos
but they start with the new 1970s version of
the intro scene it's very brady bunch looking
very partridge family with them preparing for
the baby to come putting together playsets swings
running around the town you just see a much more
lively version of the intro much more family based
because they're getting ready to have a family the
title also you'll notice because everything's in
color now because we're in the 1970s specifically
states that it's in color you also notice that the
cameras they used to film were very different the
way they filmed the scenes the way they blocked
the shots off is all meant to be period-specific
as if they were shooting this during the actual
1970s as if Wandavision in the mcu existed
in the real life 1970s like if this were the
incredible hulk tv show there are actually a lot
of similarities in some scenes later on that made
me think of the incredible hulk tv show as well
cool real life easter egg though stan lee during
the 1970s was actually doing the kevin feige thing
where he tried to create an early proto version
of the mcu in hollywood getting marvel movies and
marvel tv shows made with their characters but
one of the first successes that he had was the
incredible hulk tv show because everything's
designed to look like 1970s architecture you
notice the colors in the background of the
house or the colors of the infinity stones
you may recognize the celebrity cameo here the
doctor that's treating them is being played by
randy oglesby from star trek enterprise he was
the degra character during the zindy storyline in
season three he's done a bunch of stuff on tv so
you've probably seen him somewhere they tell all
kinds of jokes about how she could have possibly
gotten pregnant because vision is an android how
would he possibly get her pregnant it's mostly
because of the way her powers work the way she
can alter reality her cosmic level abilities
inside this alternate reality she's basically
a god inside this place he makes the reference
about fruit i don't know if that's meant to be
a wonder gore fruit reference from the comics but
his name is dr nielsen i don't know that's also a
marvel reference i couldn't find anything really
big but i don't think his name is a specific
reference to a marvel comic book character vision
jokes about having nerves of steel because he is
kind of a robot they kind of said at the joke of
the storyline about the doctor trying to go on
vacation to bermuda which obviously they pay off
at the end of the episode sort of breaking the
reality just a little bit trying to reference
what's actually going on like we're all kind
of trapped in here we're not going on vacation
because it's kind of hard to leave we learned more
about their neighbor herb we saw him in all the
trailers he's cutting through the concrete which
is a reference to the sword agents trying to break
into the alternate reality and cross the barrier
like he says they're all trapped in there later
in the episode they kind of stop short of telling
vision exactly what's happening though but we see
vision uses super speed to catch the fruit and the
funny thing about this episode too is that for the
most part at least mostly they visualize all their
powers using 1970s level technologies so they make
it look like it would look if it were happening
during the 1970s and i know a lot of people were
thinking about quicksilver when they saw this
super speed scene during the trailer we finally
actually get a bunch of quicksilver name drops
during the episode two talking about pietro i'll
get to him in a second too but then they said the
whole running joke about her having contractions
and it making her lose control of her powers and
remember she is basically a god in this place
so every time she has a painful contraction she
changes something about the nature of the reality
but also her telekinesis just throws things all
over the place at the same time they finally start
talking about their twins from the comics billy
and tommy they have the joke about them trying to
compete for which name they're going to use for
the baby because they still think that it's just
going to be one baby if you're not really familiar
with their children from the comics eventually
they wound up retconing them to be wiccan
and speed their young avengers characters so i'll
talk more about them in the future of the mcu
later in the video when they finish arguing
about the boys names and she says what if it's
a girl that's also a reference to her sister from
the comics polaris so they haven't really done
polaris inside the mcu i think this is their
way of referencing that comic book story line
as they're painting the bedroom too the simser
paint that name is a reference to jeremy simser
who's a storyboard artist for a lot of the marvel
movies and he was a storyboard artist working
on the Wandavision series we see what's going on
with dottie and her husband but the power goes out
all over town we actually find out later in the
episode because scarlet witch's contractions
get worse and worse and worse the vision gets
super serious sort of questioning all the weird
stuff that's been happening like he notices some
inconsistencies like this doesn't line up what's
happening here she pulls another no moment with
the beekeeper and rewinds time only they do it
like the 1970s version of the effect so it feels
more like a jump cut rewind which is really funny
it's more 1970s tv comedy it's just the instant
boom nope do over we're going to try that again
marvel's alternate title for the Wandavision
series should just be the do-over but then
as they redo the version of the scene this time
vision doesn't acknowledge any of the super weird
stuff and they just focus on the relative anxiety
over becoming parents with the baby thinking that
it's one baby still not knowing that it's twins
she also references synthezoid because that's what
vision technically is in the comics he's really
more of an android they do another callback to
them competing over what the name's going to be
billy you mean tommy right then they joke about
vision getting sympathetic contractions floating
into the air briefly losing control of his powers
so obviously they do this more and more through
the episode like later he uses his powers in
front of the doctor and he doesn't really question
it like please make sure that we walk this time
i laughed so hard when they did the water breaking
scene because instantly you know everything is
meant to be a metaphor but because of her powers
and the way they work the metaphors in the reality
turn into literal things so the metaphor of it
raining inside the house is literally her water
breaking but you also find later in the episode
geraldine monica rambo's character said that it
was raining inside her house as well here's
the weird thing about that too because later
akita harkness when she's talking with herb
says that geraldine or monica rambo whatever
you want to call her during the episode doesn't
actually have a home so it's sort of like they're
watching scarlet witch knowing that she's pregnant
knowing that her water broke and that's when she
broke into the reality again trying to investigate
what's going on when they do this pose like this
here when everything starts going really weird
it's meant to be them mirroring the pose from the
comic book cover from vision scarlet witch number
one in their mini series but then they have their
1970s commercial during this episode and the boxy
transitions kind of remind you of the transitions
during the 1970s incredible hulk tv show because
that was also during the 1970s it's a mom getting
really exasperated her kids their friends wrecking
everything the dog peeing on everything cornflakes
the 1970s version of the box i'm surprised they
cleared that normally really big brands like
kellogg's won't allow stuff like that she burns
the roast the blender makes a giant mess and
then steps in front of the scenes and it turns
into this big ad for bath soap but it's hydra
bath soap find the goddess within the narrator
starts talking about going to a world of your
own to get away from all your problems that's
literally what scarlet witch did so obviously
this is all meant to reference what's actually
happening in this reality the whole line about
finding the goddess within i think is mostly
a reference to scarlet witch unlocking more of
her reality altering powers inside this alternate
reality greater cosmic powers because she is one
of the most powerful avengers the hydra soap a lot
of you also recognize is a callback to agents of
shield on that show coulson talked about blue
hydra mind control soap that they loaded with
chemicals to alter people's memories as vision
super speeds to go get the doctor she hears a bird
chirping in the baby's room which later turns out
to be a stork which is obviously a reference to
the twin babies coming sort of paying off the
joke from earlier in the episode about where do
babies come from how could this possibly happen
well when a man loves a woman then eventually
you tell the joke about the storks bringing the
baby so the stork during the episode trying to
interrupt wanda and sort of break what was
happening in the reality and mess things up
was a metaphor for her getting ready to give birth
like she tried to make it go away with her powers
and they do the hilarious smokey 1970s version
of her powers when the stork is able to bat her
red energy away as if it's immune to her powers
that was just a reference to her not being able
to put off the birth of the twins like they're
coming she's going to give birth any minute now
so during the episode as the stork moves closer
and closer to her that's a reference to her being
closer and closer to the moment that she actually
gives birth until they're in the room later and
she's literally like okay the moment is now also
while they were doing the comedy bit of the stork
flying around in the background behind geraldine
or monica rambo she's telling this story about
being promoted at her job by her boss mr haddocks
i think that's a reference to her being a sword
agent and being promoted to a higher position
inside sword she also jokes about scarlet witch
having all the time in the world because as we've
seen she controls the flow of time she can rewind
things so she literally does have all the time in
the world to do whatever she wants the nature of
the alternate reality that scarlet witch controls
here is so powerful that it sort of puts people
into these personalities and these roles that you
notice that geraldine isn't lying when she doesn't
notice that wanda is pregnant despite being super
huge the entire time until she literally says i'm
giving birth right now like when a normal person
in real life walked in someone's front door and
saw you looking like that that's the first thing
you would say oh my god you are getting ready to
give birth you look really pregnant right now they
do the big comedy bit about scarlet witch losing
control of her powers as she really goes into
labor like things are flying around everywhere
everything's turning on like the vacuum the
pictures are flying all over the place and like
i said because all the townspeople's personalities
are being controlled inside this alternate reality
she only thinks that it's a little bit weird like
i'm sure there's an explanation for all this weird
stuff that's happening right now it's not really
till later in the episode that she snaps out of it
and starts mentioning ultron in pietro quicksilver
you also notice that this scarlet witch goes into
labor she also kind of comes to her senses briefly
as well saying i don't think i can do this and she
looks really serious like i really don't think
i can do this just as she finishes giving birth
to the first twin vision comes back with the
doctor and makes a joke about flying feels
like we were almost flying here like vision was
using his powers to get there super quickly they
named the first baby tommy who's wiccan from the
comics he has powers like scarlet witch's wiccan
witch powers of magic like her that was also
the name that scarlet witch wanted to use
first and then they have the comedy bit about the
second baby coming along which she immediately
before it even comes out says billy billy
is the speed character from the comics he
has powers just like quicksilver as you would
assume from the name then like i said earlier
as the doctor gets ready to leave he sort of
breaks the reality for a moment and tells him
you know what i don't think we're going to go on
that vacation because this is a very hard place
to leave like he also kind of realizes that
he's trapped inside this alternate reality
then his vision thinks about it for a moment he
notices the act of the harkness is talking to her
whispering about something confirming that when
scarlet witch's powers fritzed out and the power
went out in their house it also went out all over
the town like she's controlling everything inside
this reality and we get what seems like another
mephisto reference when she says don't worry
ralph looks better in the dark like the devil in
the darkness but before they go back in though
they also kind of get a little weird too she stops
him asking about geraldine monica rambo is she in
there you know what she's not from here they start
to bad talk her just a little bit like they know
or agatha harkness knows that monica rambo is an
asian of sword and sword is trying to bust into
this reality and stop what's happening here but
for some reason agatha harkness doesn't want it
to stop herb almost tells vision the truth
about being trapped in there and she stops
him getting this really worried look on her face
like she's afraid of someone and i think because
of everything that happens with scarlet witch
versus monica rambo it's implied that she's afraid
of scarlet witch just more of scarlet witch being
the villain of this episode maybe not the ultimate
villain of the series but at least for right
now it seems that the other townspeople think
of her as someone to be feared then just as this
happens she starts talking about being a twin you
know what i was a twin and she's looking at her
twins and she starts singing the sakovian lullaby
and that sort of brings monica rambo to her
senses and she mentions quicksilver he was killed
by ultron wasn't he then i love the 180 turn
that scarlet witch does in the episode getting
really pissed off who are you what did you just
say no you need to get out of here right now she
notices the sword logo on her pendant then i love
that his vision comes back in she's like oh she
had to leave and she clearly is still just sort
of trying to hide what just happened she hasn't
come back to the 1970s really bubbly version
of her personality yet there's a whole bunch of
footage from the trailer of monica rambo getting
punted through the wall all the way outside the tv
reality so i think we'll probably see a version of
that seeing some of that footage in later episodes
but then as she smiles this sort of kind of
villainous seeming smile the tv frame widens
the aspect ratio in the episode literally changes
from 4x3 to 16x9 as you transition to the outside
normal mcu dimension we're right outside the
west view city limit and you see monica rambo
fly out like she's flying out of a tv set like you
see the little red green blue effects that she's
getting punted out you see all the sword agents
tense all their gear they all rush up to meet
her and she's still wearing her 1970s clothing
which i think is important because this implies
that stuff that scarlet witch manifests inside
the alternate reality like when she changes the
decade and everything looks different all that
stuff she creates is able to continue existing
outside in the normal mcu reality i think that'll
be really critical for the twists later on in the
series where you know early theory she brings her
twins billy and tommy wicken and speed and vision
back to the normal mcu dimension so that when
they're older they're teenagers in later episodes
they can go on to young avengers projects in the
future the whole daydream believer song is also
another callback to the hydra soap commercial
the idea that scarlet witch went to this place
where she could escape all of her problems she's
literally living in a daydream so to speak that's
all helping set up their big x-men storyline in
the future of the new rebooted version of the
x-men movies that they'll do during marvel phase
5. we're doing the mcu's version of the house of
m storyline at the end of that when the reality
crumbled she said no more mutants and got rid of
mutants i think we're expecting the reverse
of that to happen at the end of this series
where she creates a whole bunch more mutants but
if you spotted any really big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention in the video or
big wtf moments just let me know in the comments
what'll happen is i'll do more Wandavisionbonus
videos during the week my episode 4 video will
post next week just like normal let me know if
you have any special requests or big questions
paul bettany also just revealed a really big
avengers endgame post credit scene that they
had to delete that was going to completely set
up the Wandavision series you can click here
to watch that and you can click here for all my
other Wandavision episode 1 and episode 2 videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!